so we're doing this interview at 4 30.
at 2PM today Boris Johnson started his
evidence to the Privileges committee
about whether he misled Parliament at 2
30 MPS vote on Rishi next brexit deal
and we're imminently expecting to see
the Prime Minister publish his tax
returns now you had control over the
timing of two out of three of these
things so why are they all happening on
the same day well it's it's a busy day
in politics so if it's been a lot of
busy days in politics the last few years
obviously the Privileges committee is
working to the timetable of the
Privileges committee uh Rishi suno has
got a commitment to publish his tax
returns as is Kia starma I might add as
well I think it's pure coincidence
they're happening on the same day pure
coincidence come on you're taking some
fools there you know rishis United
promised to publish his Tax Returns on
the 16th of November he's just
coincidentally happened to do it on the
day that Boris Johnson's appearing in
front of the Privileges committee we're
supposed to believe that well I I think
that you're right the Prime Minister had
pledged to publish his tax returns kirst
armor has also pledged to publish his
time I'm talking about the timing
the the timing I believe is a
coincidence I don't think there's
anything else out there I think in terms
of the Privileges committee that's down
to the Privileges Committee in terms of
the legislation we would always be clear
have been clear that we would publish
the uh the Windsor framework as
negotiated back at Windsor with us sort
of underlying about three or four weeks
ago and it would be published in due
course that is the good timing to do
this people have had plenty of time to
study the document both within the
conservative party DP and elsewhere and
it's not unusual that vote should be
held today on a Wednesday there's a
reason I'm starting with the timing
because I do think this is quite
important it makes it harder for people
like me to do our jobs properly to
scrutinize things properly when you're
trying to cram so much not just in a day
in a matter of four hours
well I I think it has Commons has coped
well the turnout has been high in those
votes uh it's the same day as prime
minister's question time I don't think
it has put a burden on the House of
Commons and a burden on people here uh
being able to do that scrutiny the uh
Windsor framework has been published
some time ago allowing people to look at
that and Boris Johnson's appearance at
the Privileges committee is obviously
something which is if you like a part of
that process which is down to Parliament
we haven't seen the tax return yet from
which you see neck we were awaiting it
was expected to come at 4pm what we know
is it will show that the prime minister
is extremely wealthy does that mean that
he's out of touch no I don't think so at
all actually uh I don't think so it
means that actually Rishi comes from a
relatively modest background his parents
ran a pharmacy in Southampton you know
he's somebody who yes he is wealthy now
but does not come from that sort of a
background it comes from a background of
immigration into this country actually
parents who ran a pharmacy one of his
parents of the GP you know it's a it's a
it's not a poor background but not an
unusual background do you think most
people who come from relatively modest
backgrounds go to Winchester school then
well I think actually as parents saved
up a lot of money and worked really hard
to get their child into a very very good
school I think is actually something to
admire in his parents
when people look at the tax return some
people may think look this is a guy who
has a lot of of wealth how can he
understand the issues that the country
is now going through how can you
understand what parents are going
through for example who's send their
kids to the local state school and they
feel that they don't have enough money
to properly give their kid the education
that they deserve or it doesn't
understand the energy bill crisis that
so many people are struggling with well
I disagree with that look I don't think
there's a correlation between someone's
personal wealth and where they are in
terms of understanding the public the
most important thing is that Rishi sunic
has shown by his delivery so far this
year and his priorities that he has got
the Public's priorities by halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt reducing Hospital waiting lists and
also stopping the boats are the people's
priorities and that's what he should be
judged on delivery of those priorities
and Delivery for the people of the
United Kingdom okay well we'll find out
more of course when the tax returns are
published and but just to talk about if
I may at the Windsor framework the
brexit deal for Northern Ireland passed
relatively easy there were rebellions
from the conservative side it was a
three-line whip I think so will there be
repercussions of people who rebelled
well that'll be a matter um for the
whips office rather than a matter for me
as chairman of the conservative party
um the most important thing here is that
we got the deal through
um and with a uh resounding a really
solid vote amongst a conservative MPS
the vast majority of conservative MP
supported it and it's something that
people said wasn't possible that it
wasn't possible to get a good deal with
Brussels that works for the people in
Northern Ireland that works for the
people of the whole of the United
Kingdom unionist voters in Northern
Ireland three to one in favor of doing
this deal and Rishi suneck has shown
that he can deliver on the people's
priorities which includes coming to a
good deal which keeps Northern Ireland's
place in the United Kingdom respects the
openness of the Irish Border and
actually leads to an improving working
relationship with Brussels as well it's
all about Northern Ireland of course
they're still and yet the eight Union
snps dupmps didn't vote for it does that
matter
well I
it's ultimately important the deal went
through as I said I think the people of
Northern Ireland overall strongly
support the deal uh unionist voters
support the deal at a ratio of three to
one what's your sort of evidence for
that
I think it was an opinion poll overnight
which the secretary for Northern Ireland
referenced today and I think it's been
referenced elsewhere okay
um a couple of big beasts of course
rebelled on it including two former
Prime Ministers Liz truss and also Boris
Johnson were you disappointed to see
them not following you through the same
voting Lobby well I'm almost
disappointed when people aren't
supporting the government
um but nonetheless I think it was a real
achievement to get that through
majority why do you think Liz truss and
Boris Johnson didn't back it do you
think it's because they didn't think it
was a good deal or because they actually
just don't really like reducing that
right I think it's a question better put
to them what I'm clear about is two
things that is a good deal a good deal
for the people of the UK a good deal for
people in Northern Ireland and a good
deal for conservative MPS as well who
are also looking to move on uh past
brexit and to look forward to a more
normal relationship a more normal
relationship also in terms of our trade
across the Irish sea make sure that
trade flows better
do you have confidence in the Privileges
committee
well look it's a it's Parliament has
voted uh to give the Privileges
committee that investigation uh it that
is a matter for Parliament the
parliament that's not my that's not my
question do you have confidence in the
Privileges committee well again I do
think that is a matter of a parliament
if you're asking for me personally or
the conservative party we don't take a
position on that that is a matter for
Parliament it's a matter for MPS who've
asked the Privileges committee to set up
this inquiry
advocate
you're an MP do you have confidence in
the Privileges committee it's not a
trick question it's it's quite simple
question right well but the way I've
been an MP for 18 years nobody ever
asked do you have confidence in this
committee or that committee the
Committees get appointed by parliament
in case some cases I think elected by
Parliament and it's properly a matter
for Parliament it's not a matter of my
individual opinion as an MP I have
confidence in Parliament structures
overall okay so if the Privileges
committee find that MP misled Parliament
deliberately and as a result was in
contempt of the house should they be
able to continue as nmp or do you think
they should be suspended well I think
that again is we'll have to see what the
Privileges committee does in this case
we have been clear the Prime Minister
has been clear it will be a free vote
for conservative MPS we'll have to see
what the Privileges committee recommends
that that is the purpose of their
investigation will you follow the
recommendations of the Privileges
committee well I think it'll be free
vote for MPS we'll have to see what the
the investigation throws up and what the
recommendation is I wouldn't want to
prejudge anything until then okay
Russ Johnson a liar
look I think that is one of the
questions that I think the Privileges
committee is looking at you know whether
he I think he's now said that he feels
he did mislead Parliament so the
question is whether he willfully uh
misled Parliament that is if you like
the question in front of the Privileges
committee I'll wait and see that
investigation do you have an opinion on
it though do you think he did willfully
mislead or lie as other people might fit
it I think the purpose the Privileges
committee is to look at all that
evidence I would want to see you if I
were
following it closely which I am I would
like to see what evidence he's given to
the Privileges committee uh what
evidence have other people given what of
a senior civil servant said what if
special advisors said I'd want to see
all of the evidence I mean you say
you've been following it closely so what
do you think so far well I I is only in
terms of his own uh evidence I'd like to
see other evidence as well and I'm sure
everybody will want to see other
evidence and look closely what's been
said so you haven't made up your mind
then I mean that feels quite significant
in a way I mean here's the guy who you
know was prime minister for the concept
but I think that's the purpose of the
investigation is to get to the bottom
the the committee hearings or to get to
the bottom of who said what when
I mean his defense seems to be that you
know if you worked in a stressful
environment like number 10 during
lockdown then the rules and regulations
and guidelines didn't apply in the same
way did you get that memory I don't look
uh I I think it's a question better put
to him obviously Boris is leading his
own defense
uh he ample opportunity today to lay
that out I wouldn't really want to sort
of paraphrase what his defense is I
think the most important thing is to
wait for the committee to report have a
look at their report so you're party
chairman you're the man in charge of
making sure the conservatives don't get
annihilated at the next election if you
look at the polls that's not a complete
impossibility is boss Johnson an asset
to the conservative party well I think
Boris Johnson is a great campaigning
asset to the conservative party uh only
now I'm actually asking Boris if it
would come out and campaign with us for
example one of my local issue campaigns
in London is saving some of our bus
routes Boris is passionate about London
buses he brought in the root master bus
when he was the the fresh root master
password he was mayor of London I think
he's a campaigning asset for the
conservative party you still think that
he's a campaigning asset to the
conservative party even though you know
people who went through an awful lot in
lockdown people who couldn't see their
loved ones in Care Homes people who
couldn't Comfort their loved ones at
funerals they'll be looking at a man who
admits to misleading Parliament over his
own actions and those of those in number
10. a man who was fined by police for
breaking lockdown rules and you still
think he's an asset a campaigning asset
again I wouldn't want to pre-charge the
standards committee investigation I've
told you things that we are not already
know that he's won by police and that he
is that uh look I I I work with Boris
over a long time he's been mayor of
London I'm a London mp uh worked to them
on the 2008 campaign 2012 campaign his
time as prime minister what I am clear
about is that Boris Johnson is a
campaigning asset for the conservative
party and that is why we should be using
Boris as somebody who will be
campaigning uh in parts of the country
for us at the next general election to
return a conservative government under
Russia is he a matter of integrity look
I think Boris is is a man who's a
reasonably well known uh what his
strengths are what his weaknesses are
his great strength I think in this case
is his ability to campaign his ability
to Galvanize voters as part of a broader
conservative family I'm somebody who
served under different Prime Ministers
under David Cameron and Boris Johnson
and the Richie sunac now and I'm
confident that Boris Johnson can be a
campaigning asset for the conservatives
and the lead up to next year's General
life but you're not saying that he's a
man of integrity well look that's I'm
not I'm I'm in the business of politics
not moral judgment calls and when it
comes to politics I know that Boris
Johnson is somebody who can campaign
well for us and I'm looking forward to
seeing him campaigning for us at the
general election and for him to be
re-elected as the MP for Oxbridge and
South ruislip